faut-il âme il s'avoue sur la voiture de
slip j'ai pensé que ça allait mal
tourner et là le mec s'est mis à frapper
pascal et on a continué à filmer un
conscience professionnelle mais bon il
l'a très mal pris
[Applaudissements]
trop tard parce que toi alors pourquoi
tout cas
j'avais tout j'étais chercher les
clients n'étaient pas là où l'espagne où
j'attendais une place pour me garer les
feux de détresse et celui sympa cette
douleur chez moi pas être dehors chez
moi je vais ça arrive prime blonde
commence à être sympa
mais c'est en 34 laissant ce monsieur
mais
non mais non mais non je laisse pas
aller non
[Applaudissements]
quoi parce que
la loi c'est la loi et la louange
beaucoup de la loire ah ben voilà on va
vous êtes garer n'importe comment non
mais protège pas de faire de l'essence
mais bon ça c'est toujours des excuses à
deux francs 5 ans et je vous préviens
que si vous et je vous donne une pièce à
la bonne heure ok bon bras
des mois 50 fois on en parlait de javel
la cliente manière un mais moins 50 des
accidents j'avale la clé merci
bon bah ce soir alors comment ça se voit
à vous les joies les mains de dieu papa
c'est plus cher alors non mais attendez
vous plaisantez ou quoi fait partie quoi
de rien
c'est parce que vous êtes devant chez
moi moi et je mets des trucs aux gens
qui sont mal garées devant chez moi je
suis le robin des bois des villes je
prends au contrevenant pour m'enrichir à
cette super et vous avez le droit de
faire ça je sais pas mais en tout cas je
prends je vous avez le droit vous de
vous garer comme un cochon
voilà j'ai le droit donc vous avez donné
votre nom et votre adresse je vais aller
voir les skis pour quoi faire non on
enlevez moi le truc du jeu ça condamne
un chalet si moi je suis crevée mois
est pas le cas ces accords est bon je
vais lui parler slip on va faire beau
portefeuille de poutres vous maintenant
pour quoi faire
et mon truc attention nous sommes en
montrant que ces cas c'est fragile à toi
tu attends que c'est une caméra cachée
stop stop c'est une caméra cachée venez
est stop c'est une caméra cachée je m'en
fous de la caméra beaux arts est une
caméra cachée c'est une caméra cachée
regarde
et chez toi ça se voit
[Musique]